cuando hablamos de texas puede que nos
vengan a la cabeza cosas como los
muestran la música country george bush o
cierto rangers sin embargo este estado
es mucho más que toda esa serie de
clichés
de hash ha sido durante los últimos años
uno de los motores más importantes de la
economía de eeuu en este vídeo te lo
contamos
[Música]
con una superficie de 700.000 kilómetros
cuadrados equivalente a 1,5 veces
españa' texas es el segundo estado más
grande de los estados unidos solo por
detrás de las que está situado la región
sur conocida como el sam bell parte del
estado está bañado por el golfo de
mexico y hace frontera precisamente con
mexico teniendo esta una longitud de más
de 2000 kilómetros el estado de la
estrella solitaria puede llegar a ser
una tierra verdaderamente área de josh y
de echo tejas cuenta con un clima
formado por cuatro peculiares estaciones
la estación de la sequía la de las
inundaciones la de las ventiscas y la de
los tornados todo ello no ha sido
impedimento para que tejas se haya
convertido en la décimo segunda potencia
económica del mundo ni para que sea el
estado que más crece que más empleo
genera y que más exporta de los eeuu
desde el año 2000 su población ha
crecido en 6 millones de personas más
que la de ningún otro estado y más de
millón y medio de estadounidenses se han
trasladado a esta tierra en busca de
futuro
de hecho texas se ha convertido dentro
de eeuu en aquel lugar que para muchos
fue américa hace siglos
[Música]
el lugar donde acudir en busca de un
nuevo comienzo de una nueva oportunidad
el lugar al que trasladarse cuando uno
se ha quedado sin trabajo o no encuentra
el camino así según los datos publicados
por el censo estadounidense cinco de las
ocho ciudades que más habitantes ganaron
durante 2015 son tejanas houston san
antonio for work austin y dadas como
anécdota personalmente el caso de dallas
no me sorprende
vamos
es una de mis ciudades preferidas de
eeuu es tranquila ordenada y tiene un
encanto bastante especial pero volviendo
a texas sabías que cerca del 40% de los
27 millones y medio de habitantes que
tiene tejas son de origen latino pues no
sólo eso sino que se calcula que para
una fecha tan próxima como el 2020 la
población hispana se convertirá en la
población mayoritaria de texas haciendo
de este estado para pesadillas de
personajes como donald trump la segunda
mayor potencia hispana del mundo después
de california donde los hispanos ya son
mayoría
yo amo agregar como yerno y como
gobernador los tejanos también lo amada
en lo que llevamos de siglo 21
texas ha liderado la creación de empleo
en eeuu desde el año 2000 el empleo en
texas ha crecido tres veces más que en
el resto de los eeuu por ejemplo en el
mismo período texas creó prácticamente
un millón de puestos de trabajo más de
california a pesar de tener 12 millones
menos de habitantes desde que comenzase
la crisis financiera en diciembre de
2007 texas que representa poco más del 8
por ciento de la población de los eeuu
ha sido responsable de uno de cada
cuatro empleos creados en todo el país
por supuesto
y va siendo más bajo que la media
nacional desde hace 10 años de la misma
forma en este mismo periodo de tiempo el
pib del estado del rangers walker ha
crecido un 60 por ciento frente al 35
del resto del país además como decía
antes es el estado que más exporta y 52
de las empresas del fortune 500 las
mayores del país tiene su sede aquí
por todo ello no es extraño que cada vez
más personas consideren quejas la
auténtica locomotora de los eeuu
[Música]
y aunque este año la economía texana se
está resintiendo como consecuencia de la
caída del petróleo pocos dudan de que
este estado mantendrá su pujanza gracias
a que su economía está cada vez más
diversificada llegados a ese punto la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es que
pastan tejas
trabajadores de ingresos medios y bajos
la mayor ventaja de texas está en la
vivienda pudiendo acceder a casas
grandes y asequibles y es que tejas es
uno de los estados donde la regulación
urbanística es más laxa de tal forma que
es fácil construir y el precio de las
viviendas no divergen sustancialmente de
su coste de producción así entre 2001 y
2008 el condado de harris que incluye a
houston autorizó 200.000 nuevas
viviendas frente a las pocas más de 16
mil que se utilizaron en el condado de
santa clara en california uno de los
estados más restrictivos en el condado
santa clara- se encuentra por cierto
silicon valley
[Música]
una vivienda nueva cada dos hectáreas en
texas frente a una vivienda nueva cada
20 en california es decir que en texas
aunque ganes menos dinero vas a poder
acceder a mejores viviendas que en el
resto de estados unidos
[Música]
tejas ha logrado desarrollar uno de los
mejores sistemas universitarios del
mundo a pesar de contar con poco más de
27 millones de habitantes cuatro de sus
universidades están entre las 100
primeras españa por ejemplo un país
mucho más grande no cuenta con ninguna
universidad situada tras las tiempos del
mundo este sistema universitario no sólo
genera profesionales altamente
cualificados mucha investigación alta
calidad sino que también atrae las
inversiones de muchas empresas de alto
valor añadido
bueno
[Música]
texas es uno de los estados donde más
rinden los salarios gracias a que el
nivel de precios es inferior al de otros
estados a que las viviendas son más
asequibles ya que los impuestos son más
bajos de hecho texas es uno de los siete
estados sin impuestos están sobre la
renta y teniendo en cuenta todos los
impuestos estatales y locales es el
quinto con menor presión fiscal una
familia media puede ahorrarse más de
tres mil quinientos dólares respecto a
si viviese en el estado de nueva york en
general se considera que el estado
tejano es el quinto donde más rinden los
salarios además la economía texana está
considerada como una de las más libres
de eeuu
la quinta según el instituto fraser y
donde por tanto más fácil de resultar
emprender nuevos negocios
evitar regulaciones tan cuestionables
como requiere ir a un diseñador de
interiores 2.190 horas de formación y
pasar un examen para poder ejercer como
ocurre en nevada luisiana a florida han
hecho de texas un lugar atractivo para
invertir gracias a ello los millennials
prefieren houston para emprender en vez
de otras ciudades como nueva york boston
cada vez son más los estadounidenses que
piensan que el país entero debería
parecerse más a tejas y es que frente a
la imagen de ser un estado de cowboys tu
amplia diversidad étnica y cultural está
logrando atrocidades como austin zahn ya
consideradas un referente para músicos y
artistas de todo tipo el caso de texas
nos muestra que es posible combatir con
éxito los efectos negativos que sobre el
empleo tienen la globalización y la
automatización de procesos y no lo ha
hecho tratando de proteger las empresas
de la competencia exterior no tejas se
ha centrado en tratar de incordiar lo
menos posible a sus empresas y
ciudadanos
wii cada semana empresas dejan
california para huir de los altos
impuestos y las asfixiantes regulaciones
vienen a tejas porque mantenemos
impuestos bajos y regulaciones
razonables y vosotros qué pensáis
seguirán más estados la senda iniciada
por tejas podría defecto trump convertir
a este histórico estado republicano en
demócrata
para 2020 y tú te imaginas viviendo en
texas esperamos como siempre vuestros
comentarios si te ha gustado el vídeo
dale a light y suscríbete al canal si
aún no lo has hecho que es gratis
[Música]